I MEAN COME ON THAT LEVEL OF
PSYCHOTIC HATRED IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
MR. SPEAKER, THANK YOU.
JOE BIDEN CONTINUES TO REACH
INTO THE RECYCLING BIN OF FAILED
OBAMA OPERATIVES TO STAFF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PICK THE HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL
DISCREDITED DEMOCRAT OPERATIVE
NEERA TANDEN TO BE HIS BUDGET OF
OFFICE OF MANAGEMENT DIRECTOR,
WHICH IS A SENATE CONFIRMED
POSITION.
LONG TROUBLING HISTORY OF
PROMOTING CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
SMEARS AGAINST REPUBLICANS, 2018
SUGGESTING THE STEELE DOSSIER,
WITH THE, MOSTLY PROVEN TRUE.
SAID THAT -- THE ONE THAT SAID
THEY WERE IN TRUMP’S BED.
PROMOTING THE SMEARS AGAINST
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES IN 2016.
"THE FEDERALIST" POINTED OUT,
HE’S BEEN ON A TWEET DELETING
SPREE GETTING RID OF THOUSANDS
OF TWEETS.
HERE ARE THE REACTION,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
IT LET ME GO TO WISEMAN’S OP-ED.
THREE YEARS, A DOSSIER NOW THAT
LED TO FOR FISA WARRANTS.
YOU’VE GOT JAMES COMEY, SALLY
YATES, ROD ROMAN SAYING THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE SIGNED THE PHIS
APPLICATION.
NOW WISEMAN IS SAYING IF BIDEN
BECAME PRESIDENT HIS AGE HE
NEEDS TO TO GO AFTER TRUMP ON TH
SAME THING.
IF I’M DONALD TRUMP AND I’M
READING THIS, WHAT DO I HAVE TO
PARDON MYSELF AND MY FAMILY ON
THE WAY OUT THE DOOR?
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT.
>> WHAT I CAN SAY IS THERE IS NO
MULLIGANS HERE.
HE SPENT $25 MILLION, FOR THE
FBI AGENTS, 50 PROSECUTORS, 500
WITNESSES INTERVIEWED, 2500
SUBPOENAS, AND THEY FOUND
NOTHING.
ABOUT GEORGIA, IF WE WIN BOTH
GEORGIA SEATS AND HAVE 52
REPUBLICAN SENATORS, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL NOMINEE IF
TRUMP FALL SHORT IN BIDEN WINDS
WILL BECOME THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RUN BY CHUCK BRADLEY.
THERE IS NO WAY IN HECK HE’S
GOING TO BE CONFIRMED I WOULD
AGREE WITH WEISSMANN.
IF WE LOSE BOTH SENATE SEATS IN
GEORGIA, AND NICK DERMAN WILL BE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MOST LIKELY.
IF WE WIN BOTH SEATS IN GEORGIA,
I WILL BE THE BUDGET CHAIRMAN.
ANYBODY OF THE OMB DIRECTOR HAS
TO BECOME THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR HEARINGS TO BE CONFIRMED.
I THINK I WOULD ASK DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS THAN BERNIE SANDERS
WHO IS TO BE THE BUDGET CHAIRMAN
OF THE DEMOCRATS WEREN’T IN
FLORIDA.
IF YOU STOP THIS NONSENSE, MAKE
SURE THAT NOT JOB DOESN’T BECOME
THE DIRECTOR OF THE BUDGET.
IN CHARGE OF THE OFFENSIVE
MANAGEMENT BUDGET, MAKE SURE
THAT WE WIN IN GEORGIA.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE AND
WEISSMANN DOESN’T HIS WAY, BIDEN
CAN PICK AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT WILL TRY TO DESTROY
PRESIDENT TRUMP YET AGAIN, MAKE
SURE THAT REPUBLICANS WIN IN
GEORGIA.
>> Sean: DOESN’T THAT PUT A
CHILL UP YOUR SPINE?
IF WE DON’T GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE IRREGULARITIES, REPUBLICANS
WILL NEVER WIN AGAIN.
>> TO MY FRIENDS IN GEORGIA, ALL
YOU NEED IS ONE PERSON IS TO
VALIDATE A SIGNATURE ON THE
MAIL-IN BALLOT.
AT SECRETARY OF STATE TALKS
ABOUT A DRIVER’S LICENSE BEING
USED WHEN YOU APPLY FOR A MAIL
IN BALLOTS.
THAT’S IF YOU GO ONLINE, BUT IF
YOU REQUEST IN THE MAIL THERE’S
NO SUCH PROCESS.
WHAT WOULD BE HELPFUL IS THE
GOVERNOR WOULD CALL IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE DO REQUIRE A
BIPARTISAN SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION.
THE JANUARY 5TH ELECTION THAT
BOTH SIDES, NOT JUST ONE
PERSONALLY.
I HOPE THEY DO THAT.
TIME WILL TELL.
THE SEATS MATTER.
>> Sean: I DON’T LIKE THE WAY
THIS IS LINING UP.
THEY DON’T SHOW ANY INTEREST IN
CALLING A LEGISLATIVE SESSION TO
MAKE SURE THE PROBLEMS THEY HAVE